[Music]
first thing that comes to your head when
i say this name nick okay larry nassar
he's the guy yeah he's a rapist he was
the guy the
coach american
doctor for the gymnastics team
that was molesting all the girls
[ __ ] creep for like years right like
tens of years would you do that what's
your poetic justice i would sue him for
a billion dollars a billion dollars dude
give him the cool unusual punishment
billion dollars but you know you can sue
for a billion dollars
the never mind
wow olympic gold medalists take the fbi
to court in a 1.3 billion dollar lawsuit
over the sex assault good
do they help
covered it up they didn't give a [ __ ]
they covered it up is that what the
story was yes that's what simone bile
says that's the that's the uh surface
wait how does it why why would they
cover that up i don't know i don't know
the surface level understanding same
that's of close uh olympic gold medalist
simone biles and dozens of other women
have filed for the news huh against the
fbi claiming that more could have been
done to stop sex predator larry nassar
they are seeking more than 1 billion us
dollars from the fbi for what if he was
a really good doctor like a really
really good one that the fbi was like we
need to have him on board and this video
is going to pick him up but but also
like what was he [ __ ] doing anyway he
was he just doing physical finger
i know that part but like this actual
job like why was he on staff that looks
like he got a finger up his ass just
doing physicals they had to do one day
to deal with one guy for physical you
had an injury or something you would go
in get checked out making yeah he was
like the senior person but because
they're like olympic athletes it's not
like hey when you're injured you go it's
like hey every now and then everyone
goes it's like a check so you went for a
stubbed toe and then he would finger you
yeah and you're like what the [ __ ] and
since they were doing well you didn't
know like you didn't know because you're
like yeah if i was like you're like a 13
year old and you're like wait what you
don't know [ __ ] and then it's like oh
simone bottles went through this too i
guess i have to yeah you might ask your
friends like hey did you put your his
finger in your butt too like yeah that's
standard oh okay
i had diarrhea in the doctor [ __ ]
finger my ass and i was like that's
[ __ ] up that makes more sense oh you
got to see more sense than having a
hangnail again no because he put a he
put that bullet
in my butthole the preparation h chill
that [ __ ] shot right out like a [ __ ]
22 like
[ __ ] shotgun i got a finger in the
ass after a car accident did you really
yeah they'd check for a doctor or like a
random person
who saved me yeah okay
the uh because they have to check for
internal bleeding it's that's that's the
fastest way to tell if you if you have
internal bleeding but it starts bleeding
no you that's how you find the blood
yeah
but it's good so that's what the doctor
said to you huh well and then afterwards
he's like he's like are you gay
it's like what's the fastest way to find
let me thank you it's like what about
x-rays i guess that's faster but it's
crazy because you don't know it's it's
hard to tell like because obviously i've
never felt that in my life yeah and then
it hurt yeah they turn you on don't say
i'm on your side
yeah yeah you gotta be in fetal they
turn your side of fetal position and
then
and they talk to you all like gentle
because they're like hey so just you
know it's gonna feel a little
uncomfortable okay and then you just
hear the glove go
and then they go
what and they don't like go a little at
a time they just go walk
and it gets sore yeah it feels crazy
whoa and it gets sore don't don't be
making that experienced face dude the
wisdom is hurting me right now
bro because like if you get hard then
it's like oh he's not internally
bleeding yeah
if you go we gotta know that the blood
source is running it's not really a it's
not a physical thing it's more of an
audio thing they check if you go
stupid it's more good
it's not just it's more like when you
get hard it's gonna happen yeah
imagine they go they go like this and
then they just look at your dick really
close
okay you have eyes on the decoration
i'm going in i'm going come on we just
want to make sure your internal blood's
working so uh i'm just gonna be looking
this way okay just let me no
no no i guess not i guess you're fine
and that's good bedside manners that's a
that's a professional that's a
professional i know my doctor was in a
pedophile because after i said ow he
goes okay okay we don't have to do that
we don't have to do that and then and
then he
what's the
the pill it's shot back out oh okay
we don't have to do that wait how bad
was your diarrhea working
dude i had to get a [ __ ] cat scan in
my [ __ ] intestines to see what the
hell was going on i had green cocka
stuck inside and then it was diarrhea
and a mixture of constipation you know
like when you have too much fiber
diarrhea and then you don't have any
poop come out for like a long time and
your stomach hurts and [ __ ] i think you
needed a colonic i probably needed a
whole lot of things coffee animals you
need to throw away your whole gut man
you should get a new one get a whole new
gut microbiome just put the old gut they
said i needed more fiber oh yeah what
would they say about the green coconut
they're like you can't sustain a life on
just ecstasy and i was like all right
fine what would they say made it green
[ __ ] that was crazy they're like you're
supposed to smoke the weed not eat it
yeah
it just poop came out green i didn't
know that it was green in the cat's can
thingy
so nassar a long time us gymnastics team
doctor was sentenced in 2018 to up to
175 years in prison for molesting young
female gymnasts man [ __ ] this just
[ __ ] kill a man
no i think torture him you got tortured
you got to prolong it that's [ __ ]
nuts for however many years he tortured
the girls you get double
i like that you get double double
double trouble double trouble been in
this video before
that's strange
it's like because what else we're going
to say about this [ __ ] guy you know
this same thing was happening at my uh
college while i was there really my dog
usc yeah the uh gynecologist there was
doing the same thing to a bunch of girls
the gyno yeah the guy that's even way
the blurred lines there are really tough
that's why i never trust a male guy no i
don't even because i'm like what's if i
was a woman well i would want someone to
check on me who has the same parts as me
like what's the guy going to tell me
about my own [ __ ] vagina which is
also why i don't want a woman checking
my penis i do so do you want a man's
hand i want a man checking me preferably
an old man so even if i did get a boner
he's not going to judge me dude he's
seen it
have you had a man doctor actually touch
her dick yeah no that's gay but they
always go from the back
you guys go from the back to hold your
nuts and like cough to your left
back
[Laughter]
he was wearing a black turtleneck and
everything does he say that just like
just to warm up the [ __ ] vibe
so i'm so glad you're not gated
it's been since revealed
that the fbi was aware of the
accusations levied against nasser in
2015
and he was accused in 2018 that's [ __ ]
up man let me guess he's gonna die in
2092
yeah [ __ ] live forever
fbi agents failed to act when it was
initially reported and no action was
taken until la agents took up the
investigation in 2016. because they're
lazier than our agents which then led to
nassar's arrests this kind of guy gets
or gets arrested for drunk driving and
everyone in the car died except for him
yeah he wasn't wearing a seat belt and
he was like holding a whole thing of
sharp knives
and the knives
his pants were like all around his
outline
yeah exactly
i just don't understand how this guy
gets away with this [ __ ] we're so
[ __ ] and then you get to live well i
get a jaywalking ticket dude yeah i live
for 195 more years
a day after my birthday four years ago i
got a jaywalking ticket at seven in the
morning while this guy's over here
[ __ ] molesting like the u.s
gymnastics team for [ __ ] 10 15. so
you're jealous is what it is jesus
fingerprints
gymnastics so you're saying you want to
trade places
you'd rather be on his end
that's what nick's trying
is that the trading places reboot
you made me do it
i was thinking this is good that's
really good but what i'm trying to say
is how come i get a ticket for three
hundred dollars and this guy gets 300
yeah he's not really free though right
he's in prison but for [ __ ] for 15
years or whatever 185 years yeah dude a
guy like him would gladly trade his
freedom to be able to molest that many
girls dude this guy i think he's got
what he wanted that's what [ __ ] sucks
you think he's got the he's already got
it all stored away do you think he's
getting molested in jail right now i
hope he is i hope he's getting him right
that's the problem i don't think so i
think i think america is keeping him so
[ __ ] safe and cozy in his really
america's like this is a national hero
you guys ever seen the rock with sean
connery
you guys ever seen that movie i love
that movie he's talking about how he
loses his sex appeal and nobody's trying
to even [ __ ] him in the showers anymore
in jail sean connor is saying that and
that was like he was like 55 and that
was like post james bond yeah so this
guy's not getting [ __ ] in there he's
like yeah dude i would love to bust open
his cheeks though give me a shot i'm in
federal prison yeah anthony lee give me
a shot i would bust open his cheeks me
and viagra give me a shot it's the
gatekeeper to larry nassar's butch
country is so like
criminal
yeah why
what's up with this country we're
spending so much money to keep guys like
him like safe in jail yeah why can't we
just die
and how come law enforcement's cover
covers for these cats
throat slit you know it's similar in
concept to like even like the whole you
know jeffrey epstein and glenn maxwell
stuff it's like people were notified
they notified the fbi
a really long time prior to jerry
sandusky all these guys wasn't there a
case against him in florida by the local
police uh and for send uh for child for
for epstein right yeah and then he got
off like he paid his dues or whatever
and then he got off and he continued to
[ __ ] people because they interviewed
the detectives that were on the case he
they found the evidence they were
building the case and then they had
higher ups telling them
but at least for epstein there's some
theories about him being an informant to
like the fbi or whatever the [ __ ] so
maybe there was that
there's that angle
to be able to meet with people in power
and all that [ __ ] does it inform me you
would tell the fbi about all the that's
the thing the vaginas that he was
telling exactly like what is his use to
anything like just do [ __ ] us
olympics like if he's producing
like winners he's not producing anybody
i'm not a [ __ ] coach but his team i
think it's the connection it's like
you're it's bad it's bad pr for you it's
like oh it hurts
politics it hurts advertising
so we rather wait until it really blows
up out of proportion and then maybe dude
he didn't get pop till after simone
biles they just keep trying to cover and
cover and cover and cover yeah and then
it just blows up i think that's what
ends up happening
and that's what happened to sandusky too
right because in america when [ __ ] blows
up it's actually good pr versus if you
just try to fix [ __ ] nip that [ __ ] in
the bud bro you know what i mean yeah
make this go away
just [ __ ] slices into pieces
just like how pelosi right now and her
husband what are you talking about i'm
talking about joe joe we have equal
justice on the law joe oh yeah wait wait
wait yeah
no paul pelosi just got acquitted or i'm
sorry not acquitted but they they're
dropping charges for what the for dui
yeah he got pulled over
dui
there's rules for for them and there's
rules for us yeah like duh and then
pelosi started shorting some more stocks
but yeah you know you know tj got a dui
for driving on his paralysis medication
no way dude
yeah so that's [ __ ] up that they
chopped his charges but what the [ __ ]
well because you'll cut funding to like
that department
if they don't play ball it's like that
same [ __ ] leverage man yeah we gotta get
some leverage though where do we buy it
i don't know you shouldn't use leverage
you get wrecked but you get wrecked
anyway yeah
yeah you do kind of [ __ ] bummer in it
everything's special interest huh
you